hello and welcome it's March 31st 2023
we're in active inference or extreme
number 4.1 and here today with Trey Jane
one of the co-authors on the recent
peace plural Publix so Trey thank you
greatly for joining
and
we're going to start with a blank page
please feel free to introduce yourself
and the work and let's go from there
sounds great yeah thank you for having
me
um I'm really excited to share some of
the work that we've recently put out it
feels very timely but before we get into
it let me just give a brief intro as to
who I am
um so I'm sure I uh I currently work at
Microsoft research I sit in the special
projects division of Microsoft research
and collaborate frequently with our team
who is known as the plural technology
collaboratory
um where or PTC for short and we
intersect across various different Labs
at Microsoft as well as external
collaborators including the Harvard
software Center for ethics the Berkeley
decentralized research teams uh
decentralized like blockchain research
teams and various different other
partners that we have
um the reason why I'm on this podcast
today is in reference to some work that
I've been doing in collaboration with
Glenn Weil and debio siddarth which is
called plural Publix
um plural Public's uh
the way I'd like to introduce it is
starting a bit more with
what is a state of communication today
and why is this paper
especially important and to give a bit
of context here
when we reference the internet as a
communication tool we often reference it
to be the
the the most transformational tool that
we've seen in human communication and
that we reference it for for good
reasons as well we say that we're able
to communicate
basically with anyone across the world
who has an internet connection at almost
instantaneous speeds and that is
something that Humanity has never really
experienced in until the birth of the
internet and the applications that allow
us to communicate on top of it which is
very recent but the reasons under which
that has been actually quite harmful to
human communication is due to the
inability to preserve what's known as
context and context is this term that is
thrown around in academic language and
we want it to be very precise about its
definition in the paper and so the
definition that we give to context is
information that is common knowledge
amongst a set of people and so what I
mean by that is it's known to be known
it's known to it's known to be known
it's known it's known to be known as
known to be known to be known to known
it's like this like iterative Loop of
everyone knows that everyone knows
everyone knows everyone knows something
and to get a bit
to give a couple of examples of that is
when if I'm a doctor and I've read
medical textbooks
when I walk into a room with other
Physicians who I know have practiced
uh medicine in the country that I'm in
it is common knowledge that they have a
set of uh they have this dictionary that
we both share and this dictionary that
we share allows us to communicate
incredibly efficiently as an example
like if I had to walk into the operating
room and had to explain to someone what
some type of diagnosis meant every
single time we walked into that room
would be incredibly inefficient to
communicate and so because we have this
shared context but also because that
context is common knowledge it allows us
to communicate incredibly efficiently
and other examples we can see in our
life are things like inside jokes it
could be cultural milias it could be
religious Traditions it could be
National memories these are all things
that play a big role in the way that we
communicate with people around us and
some would argue that context actually
is the necessary components to
communication like if we didn't have
context even English itself would just
be a set of symbols and words that
didn't even make any sense to us right
like the only reason that you understand
what I'm saying is because we have this
shared context and symbols aren't just
these like random pieces of Ink on paper
but because we're in them were able to
communicate and so
that's really important like we really
want to protect context and to go back
to why I brought up the internet and its
inability to preserve context is because
when we share information online today
is specifically on social platforms
we don't preserve the context under
which information was created and like
as an example if I post something on
Twitter about the conversation we're
having on our podcast today maybe this
is actually like not the best example
let's say I post something on Twitter
about a conversation I have at dinner
with like
um family members and it's like a joke
that I thought was really funny and I
wanted to post about
well when I post that information on
Twitter not only do my like family
members friends or colleagues who are at
the dinner table read that information
but like the set of other people who
read my Twitter content are interpreting
that information with
expectations dispositions and judgments
that maybe that content wasn't initially
intended to be communicated in and so
context today is actually very hard to
preserve like if you message something
in a group chat it's actually very easy
for someone to like screenshot and share
that into another chat or forward it to
another chat or share something from
Instagram into iMessage or from WhatsApp
into like another platform and
information just is Flowing everywhere
and it's just like going crazy and so we
can't preserve the Integrity of where it
came from and so as a result we see a
lot of negative repercussions of this
people's expectations around a certain
Community change when they don't
interpret the information with maybe the
way the community intended it to be
communicated by or
certain people who feel like they've
become anxious or lonely as a result of
this and we can reference some of the
work by Dana Boyd and Helen nissenbaum
which talks about the effects of context
collapse in the teenage uh age group in
particular and so anyway so so far like
basically what we've what we've said is
like the internet itself
has this ability to not preserve context
and that has been very harmful to human
communication because context is
critical to the ways in which we can
communicate
um well maybe we can go into now is like
why we're under even more severe threat
in the era of large models or large
Foundation models in particular does
that feel fine with you Daniel cool that
was good so
when I
when I right now I guess let's talk
about what are Foundation models what
are genitive Foundation models and like
what all what is what is going on in the
world right now with all of this so
by now if you're listening to this
podcast maybe there's a version of like
GPT that's not only gpt4 GPT but it's
even crazier if you're listening to this
podcast within the recent time of it
coming out you're already seeing the
immense impact that chat GPT and gpt4 is
having on probably you are people around
you depending on the ecosystems under
what you're living if you have been on
an academic a bit been at an academic
institution or a college campus in the
past three months and you go to a
library I guarantee you that around 50
of the students in the library have a
split screen open with chat gbt and
their actual coursework it's become a
tool that is starting to impact the
everyday work that everyone is doing
um and so
this is this is both interesting as like
a uh technological adoption uh framework
but also very scary as like what are the
repercussions that this is going to have
on people and like the reason why it's
interesting is like a technological
adoption
um lens is because the adoption of chat
gbt has been higher than any other
social platform ever like it had more
users and Twitter Tick Tock Instagram
and all these other Platforms in the
shortest amount of time possible
but it's also really scary because the
ability
that GPT like models or generative
Foundation models have
to decontextualize information even more
puts our information integrity at threat
and so like what do I mean by that
well first it's because these models are
able to create content in a very cheap
way what I mean by that you can create
bodies of essays you can create fake
profiles you can create fake Twitter
threads that
are seemingly real and what I mean by
that is they're like very persuasive
they look like they are coming from a
real human being
but the cost of creating that fake
content is so cheap
you're able to spread a bunch of
information on the internet in a
decontextualized way like you don't know
where it came from did it come from a
model or not can we prove that it came
from a model or not and so there's going
to be a lot of information polluting the
internet
that is going to cause people to look at
information in a way that they can no
longer Trust
and so what happens here is you start to
operate in a low trust environment and
what does that mean it means when you
look at information when you look at a
tweet when you look at an Instagram post
maybe even when you look at an email or
on a zoom call with someone
you can no longer trust that that is in
fact the authentic human version of
themselves
and so what does that lead to it leads
to a place in which
we are going to seek methods for
verification we're going to seek methods
under which people can actually
communicate with one another and have
confidence that that came from a human
but no longer do we have such confidence
because those tools today don't actually
exist and so
I guess to illustrate some further
examples is like how do we know where
that like a given
um output came from even a language
model if I'm even interacting with a
language model how do I know that that's
the language model that I'm even
interacting with like how do I know when
I go to chat GPT
website that it's actually going to be
chat GPT well today we have like some
actually cryptographic Primitives that
allow for that to instill some
confidence with like TLS certificates
but in the future as we maybe remove
like website domains and think about it
from social profiles
doing proof of humanity becomes a very
big problem and the impacts of this are
well discussed as it relates to deep
fakes and misinformation but we're not
focusing on that problem here we're
focusing more on the problem of
preserving context and communication and
for the reasons we described earlier we
want to be able to communicate
effectively with one another
um
so
Applause there and Daniel do you have
any clarifying questions so far on
anything
well very
interesting questions continue a little
bit and then I'll definitely have a few
things to ask
okay so where we're at so far is like
the internet already doesn't preserve
context we're scared of it
um
ability to get exacerbated by large
Foundation models and so I've sounded
very pessimistic in this opening of this
podcast but let me shed like a little
bit of optimism here as well
which is the internet
has there's this like
there's this element of the internet
that's
um like identity standards and identity
protocols and the internet wasn't born
with
an identity protocol like the identity
protocols today that the w3c is
promoting like decentralized identifiers
or verifiable credentials or actually
very recent identity Primitives relative
to like the birth of the internet
and
privacy in general has always been this
thing where it's like
we would love to have privacy and we
like are actually going to build
infrastructure and cryptography and New
Primitives to enable such privacy
because we recognize its importance
but clearly given the way that we
communicate today it has not become
something that is both a necessity for
people to communicate as an example I
still communicate today with like
somewhat maybe not me but I'm saying
like people in general with like weak
passwords maybe not always using
two-factor authentication and Twitter as
a company may not even have hard
requirements for me to authenticate that
I'm in fact a human because guess what
they want to promote virality and have
more content on their platform and so
they're going to make it really easy to
sign up and and go and create an account
and like the only thing you need to do
to create an account today is have a
Gmail account have a Gmail account you
need I don't even it's not there's no
strenuous requirements to prove your
Humanity today to get these accounts and
um
but what's really exciting here is like
privacy has been always just like
I guess nice thing that we could strive
for but the the the
harms that Foundation models pose to
communication
and the harms that Foundation models
pose to the Integrity of information to
the internet
may actually make it a necessity for us
to care about these privacy preserving
tools because we won't be able to
communicate otherwise
and so like it's possible it's like
actually almost exciting that the amount
of noise the amount of damage that these
models can do
could create these channels of
communication on the internet that we've
actually never had before like maybe we
will be able to preserve context and
maybe we will be able to create common
knowledge when we communicate with each
other that we actually don't have today
because context is clearly collapsing
and context is clearly not being
preserved when we communicate and so
um this is kind of where we now can
start introducing plural publics and
like what exactly is plural publics and
like shedding a bit more light on the
optimism to how we build towards such a
future but before I go into Florida
Publix I want to give you time to also
ask any questions you have on the
problems framing
what is privacy I could easily imagine
one saying I was right with you on the
context and I'll be the one to control
that context or we'll have a context
asymmetry where I know a lot more about
you
so how do we really think about privacy
and in your mind what ties it so closely
with context
yeah so I want to reference here
Hellenism bombs work which
um she has this book titled privacy and
context
and in her work she argues how
what we what we really mean when we say
privacy is actually
um we mean contextual integrity and
let me explain what that means it's like
privacy today is this very
um
uh
how do I say it's like it's either
public or private that is like our view
of privacy today it's like things are
either open to viewing or closed to
viewing and there's this other framing
we maybe want to take which is that some
things that are open to some people may
be close to others and some things that
are close to some people maybe open to
others and that opening and closing is
highly dependent on the relationships
that we have with one another
and this is kind of like Helen Islam
articulates this much more clearly than
I am right now but I want to basically
try to frame it which is that
contextual Integrity is what we mean
when we say privacy privacy means that
something I feel confident in
communicating with you it may be private
in this context but I may not want to
share it with someone else and like how
we decide what is private and what is
not is going to depend on our social
norms it's going to depend on our prior
relationship and our context that we
have with one another and so
um another author who's written about
this
um
is krximo and in 1906 he has his paper
titled the sociology of secrecy and
secret societies and he writes a lot
about uh how
secrets are formed and secrets are
something that I find fascinating that I
want to find a way to tie into here in a
bit
um because
Secrets it's very possible that Secrets
could be the only thing that we have to
be able to authenticate ourselves in the
digital world now in the sense that
when I Who I Am to the public in terms
of my like physical atoms and the way
that I communicate through voice and the
style in which I communicate given that
I have even a very small public presence
in my local communities but there exists
content online about me
could be enough to convey who I am to
another audience in a very persuasive
way and if anyone else has content about
them as I think it's like a stat of like
80 of gen Z's I may be wrong about that
stuff
is also able to be replicated in a very
persuasive way now
but and this is where I get very excited
our secrets can be the things that we
can use to authenticate ourselves
because those are the things that only
the person who shares that experience
with us or shares that context with us
will be able to authenticate and what I
mean by that here is like let's say
Daniel me and you on this call assuming
no one else was listening had a secret
about a water bottle
and this water bottle became a secret
for some reason because either
I don't know there was an interesting
mixture that came in with something
about this water bottle became a secret
between us and so if I get on a zoom
call with you instead of doing captcha
are you a robot or like all these
standards of touring tests we have today
which I argue in the paper our touring
tests are going to be dependent on our
secrets
is that our secrets are going to be the
way we authenticate ourselves and this
is also exciting and in the sense of
like optimism which is that I think for
people who are able to and also I Can
Shed a bit of light on the fears I have
about this but like Because the Internet
may become unusable maybe we'll actually
live more in the physical world if we
can and we're able to and
develop more secrets such that we can
authenticate ourselves in the digital
world more like the more we just go on
like picnics and like have experiences
and like do things that cause them into
heartbreak but also immense happiness
will allow us to have more inside jokes
and it will allow us to have more
memories that we can say and allude to
when we want to authenticate ourselves
digitally
um but maybe yeah so that is like that
gives a sketch of kind of how I was
looking at your question
cool I'd love to hear a little more and
there's many active inference and
cognitive science threads that speak to
this so it's a cool to hear you go on a
little more about the plural publics
yeah so why don't we get into like
plural publics and I want to come back
to the secret stuff after as well so
um
first of all maybe I'll give this
framing of why I use the word plural and
then I'll get to the word public so
we'll get like very explicit here about
both of these terms so plural
um is in reference to this broader
um community of people working on what's
called plurality and if you want to read
more about plurality I want to reference
uh two people here Audrey Tong who is
the digital minister of Taiwan and Glenn
Weil who is my manager at Microsoft but
also more importantly one of the leading
figures uh embracing this movement of
plurality with Audrey Tom and they're
co-authoring a book together
um on plurality that you can read about
at plurality.net
um and they're doing it in this like
very interesting git format where
everyone can basically write pull
requests on the book and the chapters
have these like the way that the
chapters are developed they're done in
this like very cool deliberative
discussion way and anyways you can
Fanboy over that out of another time but
um
plurality
has many different axioms under which it
it is defined by but the Axiom that I
think sat well with me is how we get
um collaboration or coordination across
social differences and I think it's
really powerful to think about that in
in each world like what like how do you
coordinate how do you collaborate like
what are like the ways in which we do
that communication often depends on
sorry coordination and collaboration
depends on communication and
communication often depends on context
and there's like ways in which you can
build up how this all comes back to
plural publics
um but now let me get to the word Publix
here which is
in reference to John Dewey John Dewey
um has this book called the public and
its problems and in 1927
um in the book he references what are
called emergent publics and emerging
publics are these groups of people who
come together to be able to deliberate
to ideate and Converse and discuss on
shared issues that they have with one
another
and find a way to resolve those issues
and it's the intersection of all these
different publics that come together to
form new knowledge and to form new
creation of this form new solutions to
problems that we're working on and so we
referenced this work plural publics as a
way
um to allude to John Dewey but before I
even get to plural politics actually I I
miss someone who is and I know I'm
referencing a lot of people in this in
this answer but it's really important to
to do so properly
um
and there's someone else here I want to
reference which is jcr LIC lighter jcr
look later was one of the internet
Pioneers who worked on what's called
arpanet is the precursor to the modern
day internet
and has this a series of work
that references uh a lot of the initial
principles and ideologies of emergent
publics and how the internet could be
this Global connectivity tool to
basically connect people and create a
more scalable form of emerging publics
online
and John Dewey's initial Vision sorry uh
jcr linklater's initial vision for the
internet and how it could abide by some
of the principles from John Dewey is
really exciting but due to the ways in
which the internet has been built and
the applications on top of it we've been
unable to get the form of public so
Dewey once imagined and what I mean by
that is like we're unable to coordinate
and build this collaboration across
social differences to the strength that
we may want to to solve
some of the most pressing problems we
have today and
the reason for that are manifold but one
of which is due to this inability to
preserve context online
and so plural Public's aims at taking
the vision that Dewey once imagined
along with the initial sketches that
arpanet took and try to reformulate the
problem uh into the understandings that
we've had with this initial
um I guess trial run of like the
internet and how we can like try to do
it again under a new framing in the
Perth of this new technology which is
generative Foundation models or AI
whatever you want to refer to as
and so we have a real opportunity here
to like actually build what you know our
um jcr look later wanted to do on
Dewey's vision and try again and we have
the opportunity to do it well now and
we're alluding to how plural publics now
can be that and so plural Public's
um in short are these digital spaces
where we can produce
common knowledge of context meaning
everyone knows that everyone knows
something in this given space and we can
both protect and establish that context
and so what I mean by that is
when I speak online I should both have
the confidence that I have the context
to communicate in that space and that
everyone who's listening to me has the
context to communicate in that space and
that I know that they have that context
and they know sorry give me one second
to take a sip of water yes
the secret water they know that oh I
think you were muted the secret water
bottle secret water bottle there we go
they know that I have that context but
more importantly I know that they know
that I know and I know that they know
that they are they know that I know that
they know and it's what this common
knowledge of context
that allows for such Rich forms of
communication to occur and the way the
way I usually imagine it is today we
have these social graphs in the world
which
um
leak information like someone might
share information
um outside of a given context and
information is very leaky what we want
to do is we want to build a social graph
that has extremely high information
integrity and what I mean by that is
both when I communicate I have extremely
high confidence in my communication
because I know everyone else has the
context to understand what it is that
I'm saying but secondly
um
I know that when I communicate that
information can't be leaked in a very
persuasive way so let me explain both of
these parts because now is how we get to
like the more interesting like how do we
build that what does that even mean you
seem like
visions that are not possible
so the first part I want to communicate
and have I want to be able to establish
I want to have confidence that everyone
understands what I'm saying how do we do
that and so in this paper we allude to
like five different technological
Primitives that we believe could be very
powerful in allowing us to achieve these
goals uh and I'll walk through how some
of these Technologies can help with
these two
um high level goals which is like both
establishing context and preserving
context so
I've I don't remember the exact order in
which we presented it in but it was like
I'll go through each of the five tools
one of which is identity certificates
so identity certificates today
are
I guess I guess there's like certain
subsets of communities that do use
identity certificates and probably the
web 3 Community is the most dominant
form of like actually getting a
comfortable understanding of the user
experience and user interface for what
that means and in particular
instantiations of that look like
um nfts where in order to enter a group
chat I have to prove that I have a given
certificate and that certificate today
maybe through the issuance of a
non-fungible token
um there's other examples of that in
non-blockchain context in particular
there exists uh verifiable credentials
Anonymous credentials there's also
um just very simple cryptography with
um like PK like public key certificates
that exist as well and so in general
what I'm trying to allude to here is
there's a bunch of cryptographic
certificates that can be used to
verifiably prove
someone has a certain property or
attestation
the reason why that's important is let's
say I want to communicate online
maybe it might be helpful to prove that
you have a set of properties whether it
be education whether it be through
shared experiences like you were at the
dinner last night and therefore you know
what I'm talking about when I'm saying
this thing or you went to that school
for that year and took these courses and
therefore you'll understand this set of
terminology or you did XYZ and like if
you know the limits of this become
proving that you have the context
basically to be in this space
then we get to the second technology
here which is distributed ledgers
and so when you combine distributed
ledgers with identity certificates
you're able to create common knowledge
of the context under which something may
exist and so as an example sorry to
rephrase it's like
um
when I communicate on a distributed
Ledger and I prove that I have a certain
attestation and you also prove that you
have that attestation then I know that
you have that attestation because
there's a ledger that we've as globally
agreed upon within this like set of
people
that we both have that context to
communicate
and there's actually some really
interesting work out of Cornell from
Joseph Halpern and Rafael Paz that
proves as to why like distributed
ledgers are actually
um
capable of creating what's called common
knowledge or or actually in the paper
it's called approximate common knowledge
because of these properties of uh
blockchains or or non-blockchain type
distributed ledgers that are capable of
doing so
um so now we basically through these two
Primitives are able to both prove that
we have some context and both have the
confidence to know that everyone else
also has that context
now let's go to the second goal here
which is I want to make sure that when I
communicate it doesn't leave that
context so not only have we now
preserved it I will or sorry established
it I want to preserve the context so how
do we preserve context and so again I
guess I want to make a quick caveat here
when we wrote this paper
we had an idea of the tools that could
be useful
but by no means do we have the answers
and in fact everything I'm mentioning in
a couple of years could undermine the
exact goals that we're trying to achieve
but to our knowledge these are like the
the best tools to consider when when
thinking about these problems so I want
to make that quick caveat
um here but the first set of tools that
I want to reference for when we talk
about preserving context is what's
called deniable
or disappearing messages
and so I guess I'll give an example
today when I go to a coffee shop let's
say um Daniel and I go to a coffee shop
and there's no technology in the room
um we can make that assumption it's just
us and we're just having a chat and when
I communicate with you given that I know
there's no technology and there's no
phone recording in this conversation
anything I say to you is going to be
only verified by you that I said it
meaning you can't go tell Jimmy some
other person that Trey said this and
Jimmy can prove that I said that because
you have no proof that I even said it
only you in this conversation know that
I said
and so what this is what's known as
deniable messaging only the receiver of
that conversation
uh is capable of like proving the
authenticity of the initial message from
the sender and no third party is capable
of proving the authenticity from the
sender to the receiver
that is really powerful actually in
information Integrity because if there
exists a group chat on a distributed
Ledger with a bunch of people who've
proven through their identity
certificates that they have some context
then any message that is sent but sent
in a way that's done it through a
deniable message
only that group of people will be able
to prove its authenticity
Matt is immensely powerful in a world
where we don't believe anything and
we're going to seek verification on
every piece of content that exists in
the world because we're going to assume
due to the nature of AI and Foundation
models and generative content that
everything is fake until proven
otherwise
and so given that given that I'm
operating in this mindset that
everything's fake and I'm seeking tools
to verify the integrity and authenticity
of information
using deniable messaging techniques
allows us to communicate in a way where
only the people who can uh who can
verify its authenticity are going to be
able to do so and so now I can basically
preserve the context on which
information is sent and so like a prime
example of that today is like if I try
to forward a message to someone else
through WhatsApp or whatever other
platform you want to reference if that
person who I share it with is not part
of the designated verifiers or the
people who should be able to
authenticate they won't be able to and
the specific primitive that I've been
working on here in collaboration with
some other researchers at the ethereum
foundation
um Enrico Potosi this is not like an
ethereum Foundation project but just
happens to be a project I'm working on
with some people from there is building
The Primitives to go out and actually
Implement messaging techniques on
ethereum with uh zero knowledge syllable
tokens to send messages with designated
of our signatures and we've created a
component a JavaScript component that
can be plugged into basically like any
application to allow people to do that
so these are tools that exist today
these are not just like hypothetical
cryptographic constructions these are
things that can be battle tested and out
in the wild today
um
so so I guess I've alluded now to like
various different technologies that
could be helpful in both preserving and
um protecting context and I want to now
just like bring it back to plural Publix
which is
if we're able to build a world where we
can have confidence in communication
because we can authenticate
the Integrity of that information and
ensure that it also doesn't leave the
context on which it was created
we're going to experience a form of
digital communication that we've never
been able to experience and I think is
actually quite beautiful
but if we're unable to do that in a
successful way
it becomes quite concerning actually and
we move into a world where there's
immense amount of distrust seeking for
verification
and scams to the degree in which we've
never seen I guess to make that very
explicit there was a recent scam that
happened on March 5th where
someone
um took the audio snippet of someone on
Tick Tock and they synthesized The Voice
from the girl on Tick Tock and called
that girl's Grandma as though they were
the voice of that person
and were able to use a various different
um techniques through conversation to
scam the grandmother
because the grandmother thought that
they were talking to the voice of a
loved one
when in fact it was just a scammer using
these different tools that already exist
today to persuasively scam someone
and so I guess what I'm saying here is
if you can't even trust the voice of
your loved ones if you can't even trust
the image of your loved ones you're
going to seek some set of tools to
communicate or else you won't
communicate at all
and this is very scary actually because
if you become unaware
of your ability to leak secrets about
yourself you become unaware of your
ability to just leak information about
yourself
I can only imagine a world where you now
are unable to access
your internet sure your like Financial
accounts and thereby your ability to
interact with a lot of the physical
world today
because you're unable to authenticate
yourself in the digital world because
you've become so easily reproducible
um
so this is like where plural publics
hopefully we start to create a set of
uh we hope to provide a framework in a
very high level framework but be useful
as individuals as co-authors of this
paper and people who are invested in
building Tech
to help people go out and like build
solutions to the types of problems we
allude to and with the Technologies we
sketch
I'll pause there and maybe we can open
it back up questions
awesome well many you're I think you're
muted then oh sorry only in the zoom
many interesting
topics and ways to go
I'll just bring in one active inference
idea and that's thinking through other
minds or ttom and in ttom
it's a lens to think about communication
where individuals don't just have a
theory of mind it's not just that they
have some belief about whether the
entity that they're conversing with like
has an awareness which is kind of an
interesting philosophical point but
really more pragmatically thinking
through other Minds points to the
emulation
of a conversions perspective
and that being one of the critical
aspects of communication overall not
like some Edge recursive case like you
brought up it's not enough just that you
know it's that you know that they know
and that's what allows the low friction
and high fluency high bandwidth high
integrity communication is not needing
to ask which of these English words do
you understand or which one of these
authors are you familiar with and so
it's um really interesting to see how
what might be seen as kind of this
esoteric or Edge case where we're
emulating or as if emulating each
other's perspective that's actually the
Crux of communicating across difference
of which we are always doing
just different kinds of differences that
we might have a certain belief about
which ones are not crossable or not
agreed yeah and I'll just put this paper
in the chat here
um a pre-print that came out by some
faculty at Stanford around how theory of
Mind tasks have emerged
through large language models and
they're capable of completing theory of
Mind tasks and so
um thought that might be an interesting
read for for the audience as well
and and one related
um area especially that you're I think
pointing to with
um this work
first we care about the cognitive
security and the well-being of ourselves
and of humans
however increasingly these conversions
also can be understood as cognitive
yes cognitive models that have
differential degrees of agencies or
capacities in the world
but it's what merits what philosopher
Daniel Dennett called the intentional
stance which is like interacting across
that interface that Turing test
interface instead of treating it like a
test past no pass
you can treat it from a game theory
perspective in the intentional stance
way like I don't know whether it's a
human underneath that Mechanical Turk or
whether it's a crowdsourced or this kind
of model or that kind of model
however there are ways that we can
approach it that are basically the best
way to approach it in a given setting
yeah and that intentional stance
we've gotten by far and well
with bootstrapping on local context like
taking intentional stance towards an
embodied human in a given party is
really easy but when it's a chat room
it's not and so it's almost like when
the comic book character runs off the
cliff and still runs for a little bit
like we're on that bootstrapped inertia
of context I have to say I totally
believe that it's really you
but again
how rapidly should that belief be
updated downwards in the coming several
months
maybe all the way to the floor
and that is going to be the issue
it's very interesting you say that
because
um part of me like
when I when I read about
um information asymmetry in
relationships
there's always been this sense of like
asymmetry in the sense that like you
don't know with with 100 confidence what
I'm thinking about even if you're my
partner
but like that's been okay like we've
actually operated with some asymmetry in
our relationships like we still make
progress we still live in like the NFL
game still plays at night like
everything still happens
but like I think there's actually an
interesting relationship here between
information asymmetry and context
collapse which is uh as we've
increasingly communicated online the
asymmetry that exists between people's
expectations of the world or the way
that people themselves move or operate
has grown to like a delta or whatever
you want to call that asymmetry
difference to be larger and larger and
larger to the point where like as you're
talking about here is like with large
Foundation models maybe become so big
that we can't even communicate anymore
and like what's worked for Humanity of
like asymmetry in the physical world
like no longer becomes functional in the
digital
um and that's actually quite scary to
think about too so anyways yeah one
really logistical example of that is
time zones I mean in person you're
always talking to somebody in the same
time zone weather condition
but the way in which in a video
conversation
it could be sunset it could be sunrise
and
the kinds of practices that emerged even
rapidly over the last several years to
help at least reduce uncertainty which
is the imperative in active inference
not to maximize reward but to bound or
minimize our surprise these practices
can be understood as bounding surprise
on these important axes of context like
oh cool I haven't seen you in this
meeting how long have you been in this
organization or oh what time is it where
you at or how's the weather outside
those help really rapidly
dampen our uncertainty and that's what
enables effective policy selection
with uncertainty about the mapping
between observations in the world or
uncertainty about the consequences of
action in the world yeah you can't act
yeah yeah no I I really like that
Framing and it's like
yeah it's interesting because I think
there's almost like a negative
connotation towards like people on Zoom
calls asking like how's the weather
outside like it's a waste of time to
like ground the conversation in that
like first two minutes put like maybe
there is actually something more
important and subtle in that that like
maybe I haven't appreciated it as much
but maybe I should be more aware of
as like yeah like it's snowing and
raining outside where I am and how does
that affect the way I communicate as
compared to someone who's looking
outside and seeing a sunny Beach and
like the small things and the context on
which we're actually like sitting in a
room and maybe like I have an issue in
my apartment out here right now and like
that's gonna affect the way I
communicate here anyways
yeah
and and one other uh area or type of
context and one that people have started
to model within active inference
framework is narrative context because
I'm thinking about those two people
face-to-face talking
so they're seeing entirely different
Landscapes maybe one is facing them out
and one's facing away so it's clearly
not enough to have shared context at the
level of exactly what one sees or hears
but there is some level of course
graining where
the people will expect and prefer to
have shared context and whether it's a
micro narrative like something very
situational hey in the next 30 minutes
we're here to do this or that
or whether it's a more broad or even
open-ended Adventure type Journey
having tools to increase our bandwidth
of communication around rhetorical and
narrative context is going to set the
stage for so much more to happen but if
we're scrambling with the pixels while
two people have different ideas about
what genre of movie they're in ones that
a horror movie one's in a rom-com then
you can't
um just pile sand onto that kind of a
foundation whereas in fact have a better
overarching ways for communities
to self-determine and build resilient
systems than we may
new kinds of flourishing that haven't
been enabled in web one two or three
yeah I couldn't agree more it's um I
think we're adding a very like the the
feeling I get right now with everything
coming out is
like we are at a point where like
we have an actual opportunity to fix
communication in the way we like never
have been able to like we can get the
properties of physical communication of
like being in the same room and having
this like context of one another but
doing so in a way that we can also
benefit from like Global instantaneous
communication that maybe we've never
actually had
um and that's really cool that's really
exciting and I think that we're at a
point now where we're seeing claims from
some of the world's smartest people
um who are building these Technologies
saying that like oh Foundation models
could be as revolutionary as the wheel
or electricity not even the internet but
like as revolutionaries like some of
these even more
drastically important technologies that
we should take this very seriously if we
meet those words the way that they're
being said
um and treat it as also an opportunity
to build around it and and hopefully
improve human communication
but yeah so I think like that so like I
think that's like wraps up like kind of
the plural public streaming and like it
was very like nice to actually walk it
through in the way that we did here it
feels like
we went through like at a good pace and
feels nice yeah
I guess just in our
Landing of the plane how do you and your
colleagues move forward and how can
people be included in their own ways in
how things will develop
yeah I guess a couple things so
um
one is I as an individual and like
pretty accessible if you want to reach
out to me and like find a way to
collaborate on things whether it's like
me and my affiliations with Microsoft
Pro or even easier for me as an
individual wanting to just promote and
support any projects that I can I will
do my best to do so secondly is that we
at Microsoft research have launched the
plural technology collaboratory and you
can read more about I'll just put a link
in the chat here the the work I'm
leading at Microsoft research on plural
publics in particular
um and you can read more about that
effort
um on this blog post we made about Pearl
Publix
um and there's a bunch of different open
source projects we have on behalf of
Microsoft research that people can
contribute to at a technical level as
well whether that be the
um
uh go for get projects which you can
read more about or the you proof project
these are all projects that you can look
at and lastly is like I think
um I do think that there's a lot of
reading and things that people can do to
like also get excited about themselves
it's like try to if you can read the
paper or read versions of the reference
papers we reference in the in that paper
I think that you will
change the way you even perceive
sometimes the things that are going on
with the large Foundation models
movement right now or whatever you want
to call it because you may see it as
either pessimism depending on how you
interact with these tools or great
optimism
but you I hope that when you read this
work you also see it with a great
opportunity to be a contributor to it
whether you as an individual who can is
technically competent or you as an
individual who can just embrace the way
that you use these tools and take great
care with how you and the people around
you use it and I think there's like
various different ways in which plural
Public's involvement could take place
and also my Twitter I'm pretty active on
Twitter
um you can DM me there as well Jane eth
is my Twitter handle so
you thoughts and angles that we could
just sort of bring in near the end
um there are opportunities for technical
contributions like you've brought up and
maybe even what will Dawn is the social
competencies being able to engage in
perspective swaps
and then prompt the kinds of
Technologies
that would scaffold
those Communications
yeah it may be less about going into the
for Loop and more about really having
the conversations and interactions that
help shape inclusive conversations
and there isn't a script or an algorithm
for that
so as the ground shifts beneath our feet
with what kinds of projects have what
kind of technical hurdles for even small
groups
that continues to evolve that so that's
um one very interesting angle
for sure for sure I couldn't agree more
and then one angle to kind of connect to
active inference and our area here
is
the kinds of information ecosystems that
are
arguably always existed but
today coming into our conscious design
and control
these ecosystems of communication have
all kinds of cognitive entities they
have true natural humans they have daos
they have organizations they have
augmented entities people who are using
typos in spellcheck all the way on
through people who are doing social
engineering scams like you brought up
and there are also increasingly purely
digital entities in these information
ecosystems or ecosystems of shared
intelligence and so from our community
we see that in important technology will
be composable and flexible graphical
architectures statistical models that
help us describe communication patterns
amongst and within different plural
publics so that instead of just saying
well it's happened to turn out how it's
happened to turn out and here's how I'm
feeling arbitrarily about whether we
should
go this way or go that way
we can have something like a design
Suite that allows uh visualized and
executable conversation so people can
say actually I'd like if the small teams
were four people instead of three how
could we do that how can we re-render
our organization to do that differently
and what might be some of the
consequences and so again without going
into technical details a policy that you
similarly abided by hopefully in the
coming years it'll be easier than ever
to make those kinds of statistical
analyzes of cognitive entities more
available
yeah I couldn't agree more and I'm very
supportive of the work active inference
is doing and
um yeah I know I I I I can't express the
the need for those types of research
problems but also building the tools to
enable that kind of inference to make
people actually take action on it too in
a way that doesn't detriment the
decision making that we have already
great well
what are your closing words or thoughts
or exhortations
maybe like the last thing I'll say and I
just like can't reiterate it anymore I
was like
this is like a really cool time to like
be working or thinking and having fun
sparring with people
in this space and like
if you just engage him in the slightest
way and do it in a way with like a bit
of optimism and like not too much of
like
long-termism when the World's Gonna
collapse
at least that's how I try to go about it
um it feels like a very
it feels refreshing a bit because
there's like if you can band together a
group of people who want to do this
properly I think that it's it's a lot of
opportunity so find ways to like engage
in a way with optimism and I think that
we can build some really cool stuff
together if so
amazing well the body doesn't have a
long-term plan it also only has a
sequence of short-term plans
and so that is absolutely the question
and the positive approach to approach it
expecting and preferring survival and
flourishing and then enacting short-term
actions so that we can really make it
work long term
the and like the we also may not have 10
years like we may only have like a year
or two to like get this done so it's
also there is like urgency I guess in
that as well
um and so it's like
yeah like I just say start like get
going if you're not already going or
like just ramp it up because we like
this is not something to like this is a
short-term need we need to start acting
on
thank you Trey for joining
thank you everybody checks out the paper
and future developments of the work so
thank you Daniel in the active inference
yeah see you till next time thank you